all right what's it Wednesday episode
number 15 and this week is a monster
week I'm very excited to introduce you
to a new monster but first let's look at
last week's skull this is last week's
guest and so have you noticed that the
hints I gave you were vacants as I
mentioned they might have been I said he
may or may not be from Australia he may
or may not enjoy eating nuts with his
hooked beak and the truth is nope he's
not from Australia and he doesn't eat
nuts this is an American Kestrel eats
meat it's a lot of small rodents
sometimes small birds and a lot of
insects like during the summer time
it'll eat grasshoppers and stuff really
cool little animals I love them and this
is some video of our very own American
Kestrel it's Jin Timoney Wildlife Center
look how pretty she is she's so cool
Kestrel czar Falcons they're actually
somewhat closely related to parrots so
those of you who guessed a parrot don't
feel super bad this is kind of a newish
discovery in the genetics that Falcons
are fairly close to parrots alright it's
time for another monthly monster I'm
really excited about this one
mainly because I don't think many of you
have seen this one before the first
monthly monster that we did a lot of you
had already seen it this one
I highly doubt any of you saw this this
is back in 2013 didn't cause as much of
a stir as these sometimes do on the
internet but it it came out on live
leaks that's where I first decided and
looking at the comment section was
hilarious so this is the animal or sorry
monster or alien and the liveleak says
this mysterious beast was found deep in
the jungles of Venezuela by oil workers
some claim it is Shiva kapre others
allege it to be an alien beast pet left
behind on earth I love how people think
that not only do aliens look exactly
like people except for they have weird
skin and bigger heads but they also
think that they have four-legged pets
because of
course they would write that they leave
these four-legged pets behind on
accident as one does when one is
traveling to foreign worlds anyway in
the comment section there is really good
stuff
people say oh it looks like a Tasmanian
Tiger someone says it's a hoax I say
looks like splinter from Ninja Turtles
that's I like that that's a good that's
a good one
what the f you people never seen a
Komodo dragon before it's so obvious now
look at those teeth I hope that by now
you have been following along in and in
this video series long enough to know
that those are not reptilian teeth those
are mammal teeth look it's got molars
it's got premolars it's got canines this
thing is a mammal definitely a mammal
what kind of metal though look at those
feet look at that tail this is in
Venezuela again hints hints so anyway
let me know what you think this is in
the comment section I'm excited to hear
what you think this is I'm gonna say
that yes you are allowed to google you
can google things like animals in
Venezuela you can google things like
what does a Tasmanian Tigers skull look
like you can google animals but don't
google alien Venezuela or Shippo kapre
Venezuela or don't don't Google
chupacabra just keep this to actual
animals that exist and that we already
know about and then when you write what
you think it is in the comment section
tell us why you think it is what you
think it is so so long for now what's it
Wednesday
[Applause]
it was on - no I turned it down